[Applause]  Devil May Cry I got a gig cash up front  cash up front  this I like  the water knees turn it on and those  toilet flushing  first-come first-serve on the targets  round music to my ears  hurry up Dante  [Music]  you  by the infamous Dante my grandmother is  now go sleep gunsmith that made all  those fancy weapons  yes I get to see with my own eyes  [Music]  Dante I'm gonna go too  I've got all the power I need right here  hey tough guy that'll keep him but not  alone  soldier boy said city's gonna hell and  back taken over by the underworld not  just here but everywhere  hey this is my gig leave her out of this  [Music]  meet your new client  he who desires but act not reads  pestilence so it is written  hey I got a new arm for you a  masterpiece what am i finest  [Music]  you